l'équipe senior de plaisir villes pro
débute l'année par une victoire les
bleus se sont imposés ce dimanche 15
janvier à domicile contre le club de
rennes à l'occasion de la 10e journée de
nationale 3 après avoir remporté les
deux premiers sets 25 17 et 25 21 les
plaisirs ont perdu le troisième set de
justesse 25 à 23 avant de conclure le
match 25 à 19
score final 3 7 1 on a pris le match
dans nos mains tous les secteurs
offensive et défensive et ils ont
fonctionné il y avait une baisse de
rythme sur certaines phases de jeu
notamment dans le troisième set qu'on
n'a pas su à un moment donné rebondir
pour pouvoir rentrer dans la première
phase du jeu et le quatrième set c'est
surtout le mental pour nous c'est un
match important c'était bien de se
remettre dedans ça nous va nous redonner
un peu de confiance
suffisamment pour que l'on puisse aller
chercher le prochain match
voilà et pas trop pour que en même temps
on est à se remettre en question parce
qu'il y avait des choses à revoir quand
même au classement plaisir villepreux
promu cette saison en nationale 3
reprend la 4e place du classement
l'objectif annoncé en début de saison
avec un bilan de six victoires et quatre
défaites depuis le début de la saison
mais pour l'instant pas question pour le
club de parler de montée avec cinq
points de retard sur les premières
places
sylviane pourquoi pas mais je pense que
les première et deuxième est qu'ils ont
pris énormément de poids
l'objectif de cette année c'était
d'abord le maintien pour construire un
et prochain pour pouvoir après avoir
l'objectif de
inventaire prochain match pour l'équipe
ce dimanche 22 janvier contre en gerbes
l'ont toujours à domicile ans
[Applaudissements]